mmm vaynernation got a serious thing
here posted something a couple days ago
Danny show me again amazing content
[Music]
so woke up super early for a 4:30 a.m.
in that in Kansas City
a great meeting last night with a
fortune 500 CEO at his home got on the
plane connected to Detroit I told you I
can change the world with a test that
collect someone's you're planted here in
comes Ohio another mole watch your
stance everybody doesn't matter see you
thought it was place
don't be stupid don't be dumb judge me
up where from
don't be foolish use your mind he step
will able take out me son I got humbled
and up GZ man I make this look easy can
stop some being a sports business to be
had failed new faces new demands the
desk changed all your friends operating
your sports recruiting we're playing
Barnes & Nobles I did it Thank You Tommy
on that second floor oh my god
I'm definitely doing this Barnes and
Nobles for uh for my February book tour
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] blow that out and
then and then recap pretty much a group
legend are we calling it guys like you
don't and how hold on oh yeah so this
position sorry mama Shetty hate August
soccer murder never heard of our
departing earning mirga's lurking sorry
Karthik I'm just going to be our
colleges here for pencils of promise
I think you like this building so you
found my nice little time left
oh one top backpack bath this one top of
my face back home
and now headed to Vegas for a speech of
giving tomorrow
been on the phone hardcore getting a
real cadence
I've always struggled to be on top of my
being a media business when I travel to
the level that I wanted but lately you
know you get better getting better just
texting with the team emailing really in
the business a lot of new business for
vaynermedia which is exciting
huge focuses I think you're seeing on my
Instagram stories and places of that
nature on small business really trying
to attack my roots trying to come up
with lower price point entry points for
people to work with Boehner have a
really cool launch product called main
or 101 men I'm a little bit weird and
I'm putting it out here but gonna come
up with something called Vayner 101 301
thousand dollars at vaynermedia
consulting things something that you
know something that I've seen us sell
for three four hundred thousand number
finding it down for a launch plan so
many people have businesses and they
want to spend their money I'm launching
so a launch plan brand positioning over
you know first back to three months of
content signature piece of video so
playing playing a lot with that what
else is going on speaking of a bunch of
cool celebs and influencers about being
guests on the askgaryvee show obviously
we're in that cadence trying to answer
questions going daily be I think that's
going to be cool I'm excited about that
right now have to reasonable that you
currently have
thanks for the content I mean look if
I'm 20 years old and I know what my
goals are committed to them blindly as I
guess my answer I think the biggest
thing that I'm starting to recognize and
feel is I'm just binary black-and-white
switch ON or switch off hustle mode on I
mean the amount of people that are half
pregnant kind of into it sorta shoulda
could a little kinda I just think it's
all in and so to be very frank with you
brother talk your account what don't we
share become that's cool I would up uh
you know my man I would just go all-in
I mean at twenty the hell
you have their whole life in front of
you and why not try to achieve greatness
ASAP like go for it like just go for it
blindly I wouldn't judge myself I would
use my fresh naive eyes people
experience is a gift and a real leverage
but naivete and blind faith and not
knowing the rules is also a real
advantage and so if I was 20 I would
just get real serious on my naivete and
go all-in blindly run through the wall
and get it done I've put in the work man
you're 20 you can live on a lot less
think of 20 then you can of 41 do rock
and I are back to back three hour days
come tough little rugged I call [ __ ]
in man I don't know how I'm gonna hide
the [ __ ] finish the cameras and I
[Music]
started on another Hobbit in a high
visibility cameras in the light
internation got a serious thing here
posted something a couple days ago Danny
show me again amazing content just
kidding kidding I posted the other day
about the 18 hours saying put up the can
you guys just put it like make it a
fourth to the screen show that video
real quick for a second on Instagram 18
hours a day what do you do with it I was
so intrigued by how many people were
like what the [ __ ] like you need more
than six hours of sleep or some of us
have to take care of things or you know
I'm a single dad like you're not
factoring it like I'm factoring in
everything you know for example I don't
give a [ __ ] like sleep ten hours a day
then all I'll say to you is you have 14
hours to me this is not about the
semantics this is about the binary
mindset of winning or losing in life
everybody's looking for excuses you're
responding in that comments of but what
about this but what about that but about
this [ __ ] that or I need more time or
people need more time or this is unfair
what about wiffle ball or escapism or or
family time or excuses if you want to
jeez what you want to achieve at the
highest level this is a binary game
either you're in the yes I will figure
this out business or no this won't work
because too many of you are stuck
[ __ ] stuck and this is not going to
work because you're still bitter you're
upset you're still upset that girl broke
up with you
you're the Europe's that's why it's not
happening you're upset because your
parents didn't have any money and and
you have to pay for it yourself like
you're upset and you're in the I can't
have this workout because you actually
got upset that the number was 18 hours a
day you have time to do instead of
realizing that's not what I [ __ ] gave
a [ __ ] about it's just maximizing what
you can do while you're awake so whether
you're sleeping six seven eight nine or
ten hours that's fine I'm just
interested in what you're doing in the
14 15 16 hours you have to do something
about it
but what I'm way more interested in is
why do you have so much poison in you
why do you have so much negativity in
you why are you losing why is that your
mindset that as soon as you see anything
about my content I'm a little bit of
weird dude I went out and looked at what
you did
other places you're just in the know
business you're in the defense you're in
the I can't because business and that's
a [ __ ] losing game so please use this
little backseat ramp to figure out
what's inside of you that's making you
go there and fix that because all my
content all these courses all your
business ideas all your wants and
ambitions aren't going to mean jack [ __ ]
if you don't think that I really that's
nothing to change the flow adjustment
when you're people in a great discussion
see this Rick Rubin will play a funny
you have enough pasta for my new sorry
sir you me great I'm always good until
the end
because I'm driven by gratitude
perspective yep I just know what it's
about
I'm good forever
[ __ ] is binary baby either you're in the
route either you're in or out understand
and most to go out nothing to mic
recording kazi's were there don't get me
sorry I dropped fast but I stay in my
lane I know one car but I system i gay a
noob in the back a and you do still
trying to say the Dippold a never gone
good that's great okay so much change
like rearranging nothing to say